et dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
les crèches se sentent délaissés oublié
au profit estime-t-elle des écoles des
collèges et des lycées qui font
régulièrement l'actualité
elle est salariée du secteur de la
petite enfance sont donc en grève
aujourd'hui à l'appel d'un large front
syndical mobilisation contre la réforme
du mode de garde dans ses structures
d'accueil elle a débuté cette réforme il
ya plus de deux ans parmi les principaux
points le nombre d'encadrants l'espace
par enfant ou encore la qualification
des personnels est les négociations sont
en cours
rassemblés ce matin à paris les
protestataires dénoncent une dégradation
des conditions de travail sur nombre
d'enfants accueillis en crèche écouter
aujourd'hui on fait ce qu'on reproche à
cette réforme c'est l'effet que y ait
des modifications qui vont tirer vers le
bas les conditions de vie du quotidien
des enfants
donc ça peut se traduire officiellement
par plus d'enfance et notamment par
exemple en passant un peu unique d'un
professionnel pour ses enfants savent
menthe le tout
5 pour les bébés donc dans ce cas là oui
pour les zones densément peuplées
le fait d'abaisser la surface à 5 2 5
mètres carrés c'est aussi plus d'enfants
dans moins de surface donc on peut aussi
résigné c'est ainsi mais aujourd'hui ce
qu'on demande c'est en fait d'aller plus
loin de dire qu'on est l époque est
terminée de sel ou mendier pour garder
les enfants dès qu'on leur donnait à
manger on changeait les couches pendant
que les parents travaillent aujourd'hui
sa demande à réel investissement que de
mettre en place un environnement italie
naissance gucci dior pour eux et donc
qu'on demande au gouvernement
aujourd'hui d'être plus ambitieux encore
dans sa réforme